With fertile pastoral plains, productive
horticultural sectors,
rugged high country
and ecologically significant estuaries.
The Waimakariri District's
economy and character is dependent
upon the natural environment.
So as we head into the 21st century,
it is critical to understand
how environment is changing.
So we can prepare, find opportunities,
adapt and continue to prosper.
Climate change is already happening
in the Waimakariri
and the district is about one degree
warmer than 100 years ago.
This recent warming
has been caused by an increase
in greenhouse
gas concentrations in our atmosphere.
These extra gas molecules
cause more of the sun's radiation
and heat to be pushed back down to earth
rather than escaping into space.
Future changes to temperature,
rainfall patterns as well as sea level
rise will have impacts
on our communities, businesses
and natural environments.
When talking about
potential climate futures in this video,
we use two different scenarios
of greenhouse gas concentrations.
One is a high range scenario,
with greenhouse gas
concentrations continue to rise unabated.
The other is a moderate scenario where
concentrations stabilize around 2060.
Given
we do not know which
scenario will eventuate, it's important
to examine the potential changes
and impacts associated with both scenarios
so we can fully understand
and explore the risks.
Greenhouse gases can stay
in the atmosphere for a long time,
so we're still likely to see
continued climate change into the future
despite efforts to reduce emissions.
Temperature increases could impact water
supplies, encourage the spread of pests
and place pressure
on key growth stages of some crops.
However, increased temperatures
may also allow new crops to be grown
in the district, and warmer
air temperatures could have other benefits
for agriculture, such as reduce stress
experienced by livestock
during winter.
Increasing temperatures
in the Waimakariri District
mean that extreme heat
will be more common.
The District currently experiences
up to 40 hot days per year.
This is projected to increase by up
to 20 days by the middle of the century
under the moderate scenario.
For the high range
scenario, the average number of hot days
in the district
could triple by the end of the century.
There is a large variation
in the number of hot days
across the region with more in the low
elevation areas than in the mountains.
The Lees Valley and Western Plains
could see upwards of 60
additional hot days per year
if future emissions are unrestricted.
The increase in hot days
is likely to place increased heat
stress on livestock, contribute
to a loss of biodiversity,
impact the health of freshwater
ecosystems, and lead to increased
energy used for cooling.
Minimum temperatures
are also projected to warm,
which will result in fewer frost
and snow days for the Waimakariri.
Frosts are most common for inland and high
elevation areas of the District.
But by the end of the century up to 30
fewer frosts are projected
under the mid range scenario
with up to 50 fewer frosts under the high
range scenario.
Projected changes to total annual rainfall
a varied in the Waimakariri District,
but are generally expected to increase.
This occurs in part because as the planet
warms, the atmosphere can hold
more moisture, leading to more
total annual rainfall in the District.
The eastern and southern plains
will see the largest
increases in rainfall,
with about 8 to 12% more rain annually.
While slight decrease is projected
in the western high elevations,
this east to west pattern
and the precipitation and changes
is fairly consistent across the seasons
except in spring,
which may experience a larger decrease
in rainfall than the other seasons.
Residents of the District can also expect
more frequent and severe extreme rainfall
events and storms as the climate warms
during the 21st century.
Such storms could lead to flooding
in the district's large river systems,
disrupt agriculture, damage
transport networks and private property.
Despite a projected increase
in total rainfall for the district,
increased evapotranspiration
resulting from warmer temperatures
means that drought is also expected
to be more common
and more severe in the Waimakariri.
This may impact access
to reliable water supplies
for towns, agriculture, horticulture
and the natural environment.
A drier and warmer
environment is also likely to experience
more wildfire.
Coastal land
and settlements in the District
could be directly impacted
by sea level rise and coastal inundation.
This will likely increase coastal erosion
and flooding, which could damage homes
and infrastructure
such as pipes and roads.
The NIWA report contains projections
for many more climatic variables,
which you can see here.
These climate projections show
we may face significant
challenges heading into the future,
reducing our emissions is urgently
needed to stabilize the climate.
But it is also vital that we identify
adaptation strategies like strengthening
the reliability of our water supplies,
improving biodiversity and river quality.
Climate change will affect all of us,
and the Council will need to work
in partnership with Ngāi Tūāhuriri Rūnanga
as kaitiaki of the Rohe.
We hope open communication of the science
projections will both motivate
and inform discussions with businesses
and the wider community.
The goal is to have all our community
working together to build resilience
and adapt to climate change.
Climate change is
a challenge that everyone needs to address
from government through to individuals.
We all play a part.
That's why Waimakariri has got a policy
in place and a program of works to ensure
that we do everything
we can to futureproof our communities
against the challenges that lay ahead.
The information in this
NIWA report is critical
to understanding the scale of the changes
that are in front of us.
Delivering a climate resilient
future needs all regions
to take action to reduce transport
emissions, improve building productivity,
maximize energy efficiency, lessen waste
and change consumption habits.
We're aiming to improve the Council's
responsiveness,
provide transformational leadership,
and take a planned approach
to mitigating and reducing emissions.
We're also relying on you as we work
collaboratively with the community
and other stakeholders to adaptively plan
for climate change effects
and increase our resilience.
It's critical
for our District and its wellbeing.